foreign
[Music]
card or a way to make the criminal
justice system more fair one group says
Freedom shouldn't be for sale while
critics say the movement to get rid of
cash bail is putting all of us in danger
are you sorry
[Music]
um
the surveillance video shows Rashawn
Anderson the night he shot a Chinatown
restaurant worker 11 times while he was
out on bail for a previous crime
sometimes people have mental breakdowns
prosecutors detail a timeline in court
records in November of 2021 Anderson is
arrested for pandering and carrying a
concealed weapon he's released without
having to pay bail and told to stay out
of trouble the next day he's arrested
again for burglary and theft the bail
project a non-profit posts three
thousand dollars Bond six days later
Anderson opens fire on wings it's an
absolute tragedy in the Bell project
myself speaking to develop project
sounded absolutely shocking in January
we spoke with the bail project Regional
director Cameron pipe did the bell
project find any red flags to indicate
perhaps he wasn't the right candidate to
help out every every single decision
that we make at the Bell project goes
through the same exact thorough review
in September the victim Chen young Wang
filed this lawsuit against the bail
project for bailing Anderson out despite
his criminal record I don't think they
care
and truly they don't care because some
man nearly lost his life husband and
wife Manny and Lilia cebayos run Aztec
Bail Bonds in Las Vegas we've been doing
this for 17 years they questioned the
bill Project's tactics while they claim
they adhere to guidelines we pick and
choose who we want to do business with
we just don't bail out a habitual
problem cases the bill project says bail
shouldn't be a business to begin with
and disproportionately affects the
low-income and people of color
for myself because I'm not from out here
Anderson told us he did have the money
but needed a co-signer when we reached
out again to the bill project in
December Deputy general counsel Katie
poor did an interview we provide free
bail assistance and what we call
Community release with support which
includes rides to and from court court
notifications and we attempt to navigate
services available in the community
based on our clients self-identified
needs but Anderson who told us he was
previously diagnosed as schizophrenic
claims that didn't happen did they offer
you any Mental Health Resources
uh no poor refused to answer questions
about Anderson's case unfortunately
because of the pending litigation I'm
not able to address that specifically as
he points out innocent until proven
guilty and the conditions of Baal are
set by a judge court records show Las
Vegas Justice Court Judge Amy Cellini
set Anderson's at 3000 and that's what
the Clark County District Attorney's
Office asked for Anderson says his
public defender then referred him to the
bail project 50 other defendants with
both non-violent and violent charges
have been bailed out by the group in Las
Vegas since February of 2021 according
to a spokesperson and 91 percent of them
returned to their court dates while pipe
said there was an internal review after
the shooting again poor wouldn't comment
on whether changes have been made
Anderson who spoke with us from jail is
heading to prison to serve 7 to 18 years
to the community
the bail project ceased operations here
in Las Vegas earlier this month I asked
if this is because of Anderson's case
and was told it was just part of some
restructuring the bail project is funded
by foundations philanthropists and
individual donors celebrities like Danny
Glover John Legend and Richard Branson
are on The Advisory Board according to
the website